whenever I'm working with young people
my goal is to be able to give them the
tools that they need to be masters of
their own destiny my name is Maggie
Matson Ella and I met teachers working
in salad nunavut canada the definition
of a teacher here is a lot more broad
than it might be if you were a teacher
in Toronto or Halifax or Montreal in an
Inuit community you have this privilege
of being able to build very authentic
relationships with your students and
with the community a lot of young people
go and talk to her because they have
trust on her so I think she's a very
precious person to the to the community
the majority of the challenges that
solid faces are rooted in the colonial
history and as a result now youth on a
daily basis face a lot of trauma in the
community currently many activists
consider that the region of Nunavik to
be in a suicide crisis right now
witnessing the funerals of my students
is one of the hardest things I've ever
gone through and I never want to be in
that position again
as an educator I will program that
cultivate resilience hope and build self
belief in my students these tools come
together to combat suicidal thoughts I'm
very lucky to be teaching in a
project-based classroom so I have a lot
of freedom this year I really focus on a
lot on art these projects because I find
it particularly therapeutic for them to
express themselves in those means lastly
a very important project that we've been
doing for the last four years is a
project I call students feeding students
in this project my students every day
create a healthy snack for the entire
school body the students are coming in
with a lot of baggage they've been in
criminal trouble known for vandalism
they're known for dropping out of school
they're known for bullying so I'm trying
to create projects for them to contre
beauty and really meaningful ways Maggie
is really an expert at having a more
open learning environment I've seen a
student go from one of the students that
maybe cause the most trouble in school
to the student that helped the school
out the most and is now an employee at
the school so Maggie's open approach to
education I feel can really motivate
kids that have difficult home life I'm
also very proud of that cooperative work
placement at the daycare it is a
mutually beneficial partnership my
daycare would not run without Meg and
her fantastic girls we are training them
to be future leaders for the daycare and
hopefully they will take over my job
they're gaining so much confidence so
much self-esteem and so much value and
meaning from working there I've always
been so passionate about sport and
physical activity as a tool to build
resilience and young people but I've
literally seen it and tasted here on a
day-to-day basis and Salo it and it's
not just about the athletics or this
performance these that come along the
way there's so much youth development
going
on when I'm working with my runners an
expression I use a lot is that when you
run by yourself you go fast but when you
run with others you can go so far I've
had use from join the running club
they've actually quit smoking cigarettes
some have quit smoking marijuana some
have even come back to school I've even
had youth come to me and tell me when
they were going through a very troubled
time when they were having suicidal
thoughts that they were able to use
exercise and running as a coping tool to
deal with that she's been my teacher my
coach my trainer
through the years she has become like a
family to me I am just thankful for
everything she has done for me
lockdown them for the town he says it
wasn't for Maggie I wouldn't never
experience of being in college with
you're happy that Matty came to our
village because he was helping young
people it's a role model for the whole
community I think so many people come to
the Arctic and they come here and
they're mesmerized by the land but what
is always inspired me is the youth that
I work with I really believe they're the
true Northern Lights I'm just here
trying to find leave to take down
barriers or challenges so that they can
shine so that they can dance so that
they can light up our lives
you